as the white house coveted team races to
learn as much as it can about the
omicron variant dr anthony fauci is
warning it could spread a lot faster
mutations would strongly suggest
that it would be more transmissible and
that it might evade some of the
protection
of monoclonal antibodies in convalescent
plasma and perhaps
even antibodies they're induced by
vaccine
oh it's so frustrating when they say all
of that and they scare people and they
admit they don't have the facts yet
dr marty mccary is a fox news
contributor and professor at johns
hopkins university school of medicine
where we've gotten so much of our
numbers and material this pandemic dr
mccary great to see you
the one thing that i want to ask you
about is research that i know that
you're familiar with we have those bio
safety labs they're they're a high level
lab how many do we have here
we've got four bsl4 labs in the united
states 59 in the world they need to go
to work right now to tell us whether or
not this
new variant binds to antibodies that's a
very simple scientific experiment it's
been done with other variants we've got
the entire world economy on hold right
now we need this answer we've got 54
billion dollars at the nih and cdc they
need to go to work and get this question
answered because we've got elective
surgery on hold flights are being banned
and all kinds of things going on well
we've got elected officials around the
world particularly on the continent of
africa that are pretty upset with biden
right now saying well why are you
singling them out and punishing south
africa for actually finding the variant
real quickly because you told my team in
12 hours we could know what they say is
going to take two and a half weeks why
do you say that
well this is a very simple experiment
you take the new variant of the virus
and you take the antibodies and you see
whether or not they bind in a cell
culture medium that needs to be done
right now instead we get all of this
sort of fluff about how we're partnering
and talking closely we're on top of it
don't worry the government has it
we don't hear anything about the new
medications the new anti-virals like
mercs that's going to get approved
tomorrow instead we have to hear the
same old narrative about get your
booster ignoring natural immunity
people want the real answer they don't
want to hear speculation right now uh
real quickly you you talked about life
being put on hold i want to get to this
travel ban president biden's travel ban
on eight southern african countries
right now goes into effect today now my
first question was well if it were that
much of an emergency why'd he wait
throughout the weekend of the holiday i
thought that was interesting anyway the
president said the decision came at the
recommendation of his covid team
including dr fauci but fauci himself has
said it's only a matter of time before
omicron hits the united states well yeah
because it's in canada this morning
south africa's president demanding a
reversal here he is
we call upon these countries that have
imposed travel bans
on our country
and our other southern african sister
countries
to immediately and urgently reverse
their decisions now these restrictions
are completely unjustified
and unfairly discriminate against our
country
and our southern african sister
countries
all right one more and then i can't wait
to get to the point where biden
criticized president trump okay just
hold on republican senator tom cotton
calls biden's idea now with the travel
ban worse than useless watch
what president biden did over the
weekend is a typical half measure that
reflects the incompetence of this
administration if you want to implement
a travel ban it needs to go into effect
immediately that's what most european
nations did that implemented that travel
ban if you don't want to implement a
travel ban because you think the virus
is already here or that it's
counterproductive then you shouldn't do
so but this is yet another incompetent
half measure
all right so here it is on the campaign
trail then candidate joe biden said this
about president trump's handling of the
pandemic remember we were at the
beginning here
at the very beginning we knew it came
from china president trump said lock it
down in terms of travel back and forth
from there here's the former candidate
biden we are in the midst of a crisis
with the coronavirus we need to lead the
way with science not donald trump's
record of hysteria xenophobia and
fear-mongering he is the worst possible
person to lead our country through a
global health emergency iq up dr mccary
well look i say out of the politics but
i can tell you this a travel ban is not
a travel ban a travel ban when you have
no testing no specific testing is highly
effective and you need to do it
indiscriminately but when you have
testing that's specific to a virus like
we do now
then a travel ban is basically moot by
the way omicron is already in the united
states certainly at this point based on
the number of people testing positive
that have already shown up from
sub-saharan africa so when we have good
testing as we do now it's a matter of
implementing the testing it's not a
matter of shutting down all flights
because when you do that you shut out
humanitarian workers researchers that
are collaborating and by the way the the
travel ban does not apply to americans
uh so it's a very
impartial it's a very sort of piece
together
discriminate travel ban that we have
right now all right real quickly because
i know you don't want to step into
politics
do travel bans work at like the
beginning of this it seemed to help did
it not with china since it was coming
from there
yeah absolutely look it slowed it down
and we could have done more right so so
but now if you say it's already here i
said it's in canada because they've
already confirmed cases um how do we
slow these things down and as you know
delta came to we didn't i don't
understand how they got to this
particular move is what i'm saying with
this biden administration
well look it makes people feel good when
you have a travel ban after testing has
matured like we do now and look i'm not
opposed to a travel ban right now but
it's got to be more flexible when you
have humanitarians and medical
researchers trying to get back and forth
and that
people
people trying to get back to a funeral
look i think i think non-essential
travel at this point could be put on
hold until we get that experiment done
in the bsl4 lab but the idea that we
have you know we've got this taken care
of because we've done a partial ban in
the future that doesn't work
yeah i mean i just look at the holiday
that we just had and how many people
were going all over the world and how
you know just a few days ago
the united states virgin islands opened
its travel back and forth with parts of
the african continent specifically south
africa that means you've got people
traveling back and forth so if it's an
emergency stop it but we waited until
after the holiday your last quick
thought on that we'll move on
look we really knew about this on
november 10th so the idea is somehow
like we acted as soon as we got the
information that's not actually accurate
yeah wow new york governor kathy hokel
declaring a disaster emergency in the
city on friday
she signed an executive order letting
state hospitals limit non-essential
procedures
she said in a statement we continue to
see warning signs of spikes this
upcoming winter and while the new
omicron variant has yet to be detected
in new york state
it's coming both new york state and city
have seen notable increases in the seven
day rolling average of covid19 cases and
hospitalizations compared to last month
what would you say to the governor about
that
well elective surgery is not binary it's
still
very important to do elective surgery
hip replacements aortic aneurysm repair
cancer resection so when we stop
elective surgery it has massive
implications for health and by the way i
think what's driving a lot of that is
just the staffing shortages that people
are not willing to admit are from a
non-flexible vaccine mandate if it were
a little flexible to account for natural
immunity and some other exemptions we
wouldn't have these massive walkouts
that we're having now when chemotherapy
shortages nationwide
but if we're going to have a halt on
elective surgery in new york because of
a theoretical variant that may evade
natural may evade immunity which is
highly unlikely by the way we're going
to be in this state in perpetuity
because variance will form
forever
and just real quickly dr mccary we know
that we're expecting to hear from
president biden uh later this hour on
the omicron spread what would you like
for him to say and does he have any
cleanup on aisle seven to do with with
regard to how he's handling this well
look i'd love the biden administration
to recognize natural immunity it's been
their greatest failure but i would say
give people hope and assurance because
we don't have any evidence that it's
going to evade immunity 95 of the spike
protein is identical to previous
variants so we have a lot of reasons to
believe that despite the number of
mutations on the omicron
surface that immunity from vaccination
or natural immunity encompasses that and
the new antiviral medications are pan
coronavirus
antivirals so they will work against all
variants and we'll have those very soon
i'd love for them also to talk about
fluvoxamine it's a medication that
doesn't have the controversy of hydroxy
and ivermectin randomized controlled
trials published in the top medical
journal show that it reduced death by 91
you never hear the bite administration
talk about these therapeutics like
fluvoxamine and you never hear them talk
about natural immunity people need hope
right now and if you're immune i think
people need to live their lives
wow they need you to go there and just
knock on the door and make sure those
things are said dr mccary maybe they'll
watch right here good to see you thank
you i feel calmer already information
does that for you right truth and
information thank you